[Music]
oh
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud L proud proud and do not
give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them maybe I was
wrong it could
be maybe I was way off B about moms for
Liberty I mean they're in the threesoms
and gay [__] right so like what's the
big deal
I don't know maybe it's the [__]
hypocrisy maybe it's the hypocrisy and
the [__] lies they love the lies
don't they they [__] Love Lies they
love lies apparently the one of the
co-founders of the moms for Liberty who
is in the sack for Ronda santis no pun
intended I wonder if Ron and Bridget and
Christian
Ziggler I wonder if they got down and I
wonder if Ron and Christian cross swords
I don't know look I don't have a problem
with orgies I don't have a problem with
threesoms I really don't give a [__]
what you do in your bedroom as long as
it's consensual and legal but apparently
the
Ziggler not only do they like to have
you know orgies but they Christians
Ziggler apparently likes to have uncons
sex otherwise known as
rape I mean are we surprised by this
really though that these [__] people
are absolute [__] hypocrites
are we these it's Min [__] over there
at moms for Liberty I I saw that
nickname Manaj [__] you know we used to
call him the the car the minivan Taliban
the [__] with
casseroles and now they're the Min
[__] I mean this is not surprising that
these [__]
people are running around with their
little secret lifestyles in the bedroom
and then [__] trying to legislate and
ban people from having their lifestyles
in their bedroom not surprising at all
you know what's funny about this whole
thing is when the Nazis actually take
power right when the Nazis take power in
this country if we let them we the
people because it's our vote that's
going to stop these stupid
[__] it's our
vote but if we let these Nazis take
power the first ones that are going to
go are stupid [__] like Bridget and
Christian Ziggler down in
Florida because they'll find out about
their [__] secret sexual lifestyle we
we know we know Republicans are [__]
having orgies in Washington we know that
Madison cauthorne eluded to it on one
[__] obscure podcast Someone caught
it put it on the internet and they
[__] ousted him from his
congressional
seat I mean [__] the only reason why
they kept they kept George Santos the
former drag queen and and gay man openly
gay
man is because they needed his [__]
vote George Santos apparently is gonna
get an HBO movie it's goingon to be
starring Anthony devolder
though you know you know George Santos
is is going to go try out to play
himself in this [__] movie are you
serious HBO you're going to do a [__]
movie oh my
God nothing surprises me anymore it's
not surprising at all it's all one big
[__] dumpster fire with the
Republican party and it's a bunch of
three-ways with the Republicans we got
cocaine sex orgies
right we got George Santos outing two or
three of his colleagues everything comes
in threes with these people and then we
have the threesome with Donald Trump
Kevin McCarthy and Liz Cheney that's
right one big [__] threesome it's the
party of the threeway you know I don't
know maybe the Republican Party Ain't
that bad if that's all they want to do
is have some [__] three-ways I'm not
against people having three-ways folks
frankly I [__] encourage it I
actually think it's [__] ridiculous
that state pass that states pass laws
against polygamy if people want to have
consensual marriages between a multiple
of people who get what the [__] is it
your [__] business whose [__]
business is it yours if it's [__]
consensual get the [__] out of here with
this
nonsense that's what I'm trying to fight
for is for the Liberty to do what the
[__] you want to have actually have
[__] freedom of be who you want to be
love who you want to love stay the [__]
out of my [__] bedroom right that's
the whole point cuz if you can't have
simple living Liberty in your [__]
house you ain't going to have Liberty
outside that [__] house period and
that's what the that's the whole point
of this whole [__] crazy ass [__]
that we're going through right now is
these people want rules for thee not me
moms for Liberty want to tell people you
can't be gay but we're gonna be gay in
our bedroom and then they get mad they
get mad when the world finds out about
it and points at them go you [__]
Hypocrites and they're like look that's
our private relationship you shouldn't
get you shouldn't be getting involved in
our private Rel yeah that's what we've
been telling you
[__] that's what we've been
[__] screaming the whole time is stay
the [__] out of people's business you
[__]
[__] don't be telling parents what they
can have their [__] kids read don't
be telling parents that they can't
encourage their lgbtq teen to be who
they want to be
[__] [__] you [__] off all the
way the [__] off you [__] Nazis
listen when the everybody knows that
that that the higher echelons of Nazi
Germany were [__] we gay [__] there's
there's there's good cause and good
evidence to show that Adolf
Hitler was had some homosexual
tendencies
which that's not the
worst thing about Hitler trust me nor is
it the worst thing about Bridget and
Christian
Ziggler the fact that they had three
ways I could give a [__]
less could care less if they want to
[__] who they want to
[__] it's the fact that these
[__] are spending time minute
energy and and money and political
Capital to make people to make people
[__] not do what they're doing [__]
you [__] you and and again we're all
human none of us are [__] perfect I'm
not perfect you're not perfect no one's
perfect we're and and if and if you
strive to be perfect you're doing it
wrong you're doing what they're
doing it's trying to repent for your own
own what you view as Sin and you may
think that that that homosexual
relationships are sinful and not natural
you may think that you may practice that
good you have the right and the Liberty
to practice that you do but you don't
have the right to force anyone else you
don't have the [__]
right the freedom to oppress the rights
of other [__]
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
morons
okay and I that's what I try to look
through every [__] issue every
[__] thing I come across every piece
of news every [__] thing I try to
look through that
lens I try I try to make sure that
lens is the main
focus of every single piece of
commentary that I develop and people are
some people are mad at me over the
weekend because I criticize Liz Cheney
you're just now seeing that I'm
criticizing Liz Cheney get the [__] out
of here I've criticized Liz Cheney since
the day she went to the floor of the
house to tell the world that Donald
Trump had lost 190 days after the
[__] election this [__] [__] you
pay me for the book profit [__] is
getting
old and let me tell you something Liz
Cheney owes all of America and the email
lady apologies cuz this [__] [__] is
running around saying what [__] what
Hillary Clinton was saying in 2016 and
what the rest of us has said since that
[__] came down the golden
escalator okay and all of a sudden it's
groundbreaking oh people are like oh my
god look Liz Cheney is saying [__] that
people have been saying for 10 [__]
years get the [__] out of here with this
nonsense Liz Cheney going on a tour
telling us all what the [__] we already
know get the [__] out of here man and
some people think it's groundbreaking
because Liz Cheney is speaking out
against Donald Trump folks folks get
your [__] head straight Liz Cheney
doesn't give a [__] about democracy she
doesn't give a [__] about liberalism
frankly she she wants thin veiled
conservatism as [__]
fascism she she [__] voted for Trump
twice Liz Cheney is supposed to be some
kind of smart [__] and we're
supposed to listen to her now but she
didn't see all the signs that she seeing
now that we all was [__] yelling and
screaming at her [__] her [__] her [__]
her [__] her now I mean most people like
Tony you don't want Liz Cheney to speak
out yeah but I would have liked if Liz
Cheney would have been saying that [__]
in 16 and 20 and not waited 190 days to
go to the house for when she was in
leadership
to say that [__] Trump lost and and
this hanging on to the Republican party
that she's doing if you don't notice
that of what her goal is here is to
revive the Republican party when it's
[__] dead [__] you [__] you and your
[__] cognitive dissonance anyone who
looks at Liz Cheney as a hero for
Liberty and democracy you have cognitive
dissidence that you're dealing with and
it's only because it's only because
she's saying the [__] you want to hear
again folks I can sit here and say the
[__] you want to hear and man I I I my
audience would probably be three times
as big hell I'd probably have two
million [__] subscribers if I just
said the [__] you want to hear but it
ain't the [__] truth just because you
want to hear it doesn't mean it's the
[__] truth and the truth is Liz
Cheney is a [__] Nazi I don't give a
[__] how you frame it she just hates
Trump okay that's it she hates Trump
that's
it that's it period She Hates
Trump and that somehow that makes her a
hero and it makes her some kind of Ally
of democracy [__] you hey hey one of the
founders of the Lincoln project Steve
Schmidt he's supposed to be some kind of
[__] hero for democracy too he's
behind the dean Phillips campaign folks
you g to [__] talk about how he's
some hero because he helped start the
Lincoln project and he spoke out against
Trump and he hates Trump [__]
trying to get Trump
elected [__] you [__] you and and your
[__] stupid your stupid cognitive
dissonance I'm not gonna sit here and
lie to you I'm not gonna sit here and
not give you the [__] truth Liz
Cheney thinks she says the [__] about
women she doesn't want women have
[__] rights to their own [__]
Health Care their own [__] privacy
and doctor's
office and you're going to sit here and
tell me that she's some kind of friend
to your [__] rights Liz Cheney Liz
Cheney believes that Democrats want to
kill babies and abort babies that once
they're out of the womb she said that
[__] [__] she said that
[__] Donald Trump says he post on truce
social fraud social that he admits that
Kevin McCarthy did come down to Mar Lago
he admits that Kevin McCarthy did talk
to Liz Cheney this is the whole
Republican Threesome that I'm talking
about it's the taale of three liars here
it's the tale of three liars Liz Cheney
Kevin McCarthy and Donald Trump none of
them have credibility none of them none
of
them yeah and some people are talking
about the L Lincoln project rejected
Steve but that's because Steve's got
[__] skeletons in his closet after
the whole [__] thing with the one guy
that look no one's perfect all right no
one's perfect and I'm glad that Liz
Cheney is is using her hatred for Trump
to try to appear to be defending
democracy but folks she's saying the
same [__] Hillary Clinton
said in
same [__] it's not
groundbreaking it's not [__] Earth
shattering and it's not earth shattering
that Liz Cheney is saying it at this
point Jesus Christ they just because she
did the bare minimum and told the truth
that Trump lost they outed her from the
they ousted her from the Republican
party and by the time she got to be on
the January 6 select committee she was
already going to be primaried and
already going to be ousted from the
Republican party they knew that
[__] so she went on to be on the select
committee which was bare minimum work
for a a repu a former Republican leader
in the house and to admit the truth if
we're gonna sit here and say that Liz
Cheney admitting the truth now is some
kind of [__] hero complex you get the
[__] out of
here
get the [__] out of here and for a book
and that's the other thing that people
don't clearly see that Liz Cheney is
doing this to sell books [__] you pay me
it's the [__] you pay me
[__] she's doing it to sell
books some people will say oh well she's
really trying to support candidates and
she supported Democrats and and races
and stuff I get it I get it I get it I
get it I get it I get it but I'm going
to show you a clip in an interview over
the weekend where she was asked directly
if she thinks the Democrats should have
control of the Congress and she
hesitated she
hesitated and I know I know I know it
feels like well Tony she's on your side
she's not on our side folks she's not
and you start doing that [__] you're
going to have a slow walk to [__]
fascism because to think that Liz Cheney
is some kind of friend to democracy and
rights is a bunch of [__] she
conflates she conflates
BLM with all kinds of
[__] she ain't no she ain't no friend to
[__] minorities in this country she
ain't no go look at her [__] stance
on
immigration she voted with Trump almost
90% of the time and voted for him
twice now I'm glad I'm glad that Liz
Cheney is speaking
out but do you think that Liz Cheney is
saying the same [__] that Hillary
Clinton said in 2016 is going to change
any kind of game here do you think that
do you believe
that do you think that Liz Cheney is
somehow going to
single-handedly move the
needle I mean I know what she's trying
to do she's trying to get someone else
to win the
nomination and Ronda santis is finished
I don't know if you noticed that and
Nikki Haley is [__]
lukewarm let me give you let me give you
an Insight on how it's going to work
with the Republican primary let me give
you a little insight how it's going to
work Trump's gonna win the Iowa caucus
he's going to win the Iowa caucus he's
going to go to New Hampshire and he's
going to win he's going to win in South
Carolina okay the only chance that any
of these scumbags have to win Ronda
santz has put every single [__] dime
every single [__]
dime every [__] single dime into Iowa
because if he doesn't win Iowa then he's
[__] he's out it's done it's
over Nikki Haley can't win without
winning New Hampshire and South Carolina
I don't know why you wouldn't think that
South Carolina is significant for Nikki
Haley but if she loses in South Carolina
that's it that's her home state she was
the [__] Governor
there that's been her whole [__] card
the whole time is that she's gonna win
South
Carolina some people are asking about my
voice yeah it's a little strained I'm
still working it out I didn't talk much
yesterday because I didn't I I didn't
want to lose my voice I'm coming to the
end of my my crazy you know voice stuff
and I don't have it costs as much um a
few fits here and there but everything's
going fine it's just my sinus is rain as
all it is so I'm just coming to the end
of that so it is a little strain today
because I haven't exercised my voice
maybe exercising we we'll get it going
here and I know a lot of people aren't
liking that I'm not going to Liz Cheney
this morning but honestly folks again
I'm not going to come here and say the
[__] that just because you want to hear
it that is not what I
do I'm gonna give you the [__] truth
and the truth is Liz Cheney seems to be
on our side now but you give it just a
little bit of time and she ain't going
to
be she ain't going to
be
and this three-way between her Kevin
McCarthy and Trump this lying three-way
the same way that there's three ways in
moms for Liberty oh my God I cannot
believe I cannot believe that they they
expose themselves this way by letting
their co-founder and the head of the GOP
in Florida now they're all calling for
this Christian Ziggler is that their
ain't that their name is it Ziggler what
the [__] is their name godamn
it yeah Ziggler yeah
Ziggler they're calling even Ronda
santis is calling for him to
resign I mean I don't know maybe
maybe maybe Christian Ziggler should
call for Ronda santis to pull out I
don't
know since since Ron's asking him to to
leave the three-way maybe uh maybe
Christian Ziggler should call for Ronda
santis to pull
out I don't
know apparently these two people the
Ziggler are really good friends with
Byron Donalds and his wife I wonder if
they
[__] I'm just wondering I'm just
asking questions what do you want from
me and if you don't if you don't see
that this is the [__] end of moms for
Liberty and their front group for Ronda
santis because that moms for Liberty is
a front group for Ronda santus like
proud boys and the oathkeepers were for
Trump same [__]
thing just just a a a a gloss over Nazi
group bunch of glossed over
Nazis Pimping Pimping for for a a bunch
of fascist to take power that's it it's
all it is it's all it is and they're
[__] hypocrites shouldn't be
surprising in the Republican Party
honestly I don't even know why they hide
that they're [__] sexual deviants
[__] they know we like sexual deviants
come on over to the other side
[__] you ain't got to hide from
it [__] we love sexual deviants over on
the left don't we Hells to the yeah we
love demons we're Satanist we're all
kinds of crazy [__] over here I mean you
guys accused us of all kinds of [__]
let's do
it yeah we're a bunch of sexual
degenerates over here on the left so
come on come on over come on over stop
[__] stop [__] trying to denigrate
people trying to OU people from society
trying to legislate people out of
existence put down your Bible and pick
up your condoms and come on over to the
left you know they're Monster Liberty
always talking about [__] mask and
mask mandates I wonder if they mandated
dick covers during their orgies you know
what I mean I don't know maybe they
weren't maybe they weren't maybe they
weren't against getting pennis Silling
shots after you know your your dick blew
up after the orgy [__] I don't know I
don't know I I I'm just going off what
their views of science are now with
covid and lockdowns and mask mandates as
if that [__] even [__] exist anyways
these people are [__] pure blooded
blooded Hypocrites and let me tell you
something anyone out there who's with
the moms for liberty or likes the moms
for liberty or think they're a good
organization you're the first ones that
the Nazis are going to cut your [__]
heads off you dummies you're the first
[__] when they find out about
how your [__] hypocrisy you're the
first ones they're going to put in front
of firing squads doubt me doubt me [__]
doubt me oh boy oh boy what a week it's
gonna be it's GNA be big news this week
with George Santos being
ousted um Israel bombing south of Gaza
[__] Yahoo is really trying to keep
his power hold in Israel and he's really
going balls deep into
um into us not being able to support
Israel's [__] war in
Gaza yeah he he's a [__] right-winger
I told you this [__] and I told you from
the very beginning you better be on the
side of humanity here and you better be
on the side of everyone receiving
Liberty and just as Hamas those [__]
Theocratic
fascist hate [__] Liberty don't want
you to have freedom don't want
Palestinians to have freedom neither
does
Netanyahu and his days are numbered in
Israel it seems to be that's why and
overnight they've they've let people
know in South Gaza to get out of Gaza
like where the [__] are they gonna go
where the [__] are they gonna go um
obviously they're trying to you know
get get Hamas here because that's the
only way you get rid of Hamas is is is
[__] Force but let me tell you
something BB Netanyahu is not the leader
that they need because he's a piece of
[__] and he'll
leave dead bodies in his wake just like
Hamas will yeah that's right BB
Netanyahu is no better than [__]
Hamas they're one and the same they're
Theocratic fascist they're [__]
right-wingers and this is what happens
this is what happens when you let
[__] right-wingers and Theocratic
fascists take over governments they
[__] kill people they [__] kill
people it's what they do they [__]
kill people they kill humans they they
have no [__] regard for human life
whatsoever and if you think that that
Hamas is is the [__] savers of the
Palestinians you're [__] you need your
[__] head check too you're a dumb
[__] if you think the Arab world
and Hamas is some [__] Savior for
Palestinians you haven't done your
[__] homework you just listen to the
[__] propag Anda the same way as if
you think BB Netanyahu is some kind of
Savior for Israel you're a [__]
bonehead and the stupid this The Killing
and the stupidity of the killing will
continue over there until something
changes either Hamas is gone and
Netanyahu is gone maybe they can get to
a solution to where everyone can receive
Liberty in that region or not my guess
is
not my guess is not because um you know
when you shake it down democracy is
democracy and the democracy has allowed
BB Netanyahu that right-wing
[__] to continue his powerold even after
his [__] indictments and criminal
trials and he's a [__]
crook and the same way is Palestinians
have kept Hamas in power and protect
them [__] you if you think Palestinians
haven't protected Hamas now they're
[__] propagated and lied to and
delusional that somehow Hamas is their
protector and it's really easy when you
have some [__] [__] like
nanahu at the helm of their of their
enemy all this [__] is true all at the
same time
folks all of it's true all at the same
time all of
it just like the Republican party is
dead and there ain't a goddamn thing Liz
Cheney can do about it that's the truth
here's some more truth go join the book
club if you want to win every single
argument they're going to start reading
win every argument Min ass son's book
you know his his show has been cancel on
innbc but I guess it's going on till
January but you can read the book in the
[__] F book club on Discord go to the
Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com let me show you where you
can go just go to the Tony michaels.com
head up at the top hit subscribe first
then pan on down to memberships and
you'll see the book club right here make
sure make sure that you that you verify
yourself when going and joining
Discord okay make sure to make sure to
verify you just hit the green check mark
um you'll know what I'm talking about
when you get there but go join the
Discord to get into the book club you
don't have to do all the other Discord
stuff if you don't want to there's a lot
of fun stuff in there the whole [__]
them fam's there they're all they're all
chatting all the time hell they're
starting right now chatting right now
speaking of chatting if you want to get
your your super chat on the air go to
venmo here's the link right here on
Theon michaels.com send me a venmo a
venmo chat and I'll get you up on screen
today also you can buy me a shot
Jagermeister helps my voice out and it
helps me sleep and get my
rest so if you wanna if you want to help
Tony out with his voice go buy Tony a
shager or you can if you swear as much
as I do you can you can put some money
in the swear jar and then don't forget
your Christmas gifts this holiday we've
got [__] a merch going on in the store
um the tattoo merch collection here let
me show you here's a hoodie here's
another hoodie it's getting cold outside
if you want it on the the the the this
machine kills fascism
tattoo design on the front or on the
back we've got those at the tattoo merch
collection store again just go to Theon
michaels.com it's really important that
you go if you want to get it by
Christmas I think they sent me the dates
this morning uh if you get it this week
then um then you'll have it by Christmas
you know what I'll do tomorrow I'll get
you a a promo code I'll get you a
Christmas promo code I mean if you want
to buy it today at full price and helps
out the show but if you if you want to
wait for I'll get you a promo code that
way you can order it in time for
Christmas also get your my dog even my
dog hates Ted Cruz merch and even my cat
hates hates Ted Cruz merch you get
coffee mugs you can get sweaters and
t-shirts on those as well it's on a
different store on there but you can
click the link here and get those as
well I appreciate all the support that
you guys give the show you you are what
keeps this microphone powered against
fascism you are the one you are why I'm
here you're how I speak so rather you
join the patreon but you want to join
the patreon you just pan out a
memberships on the Tony michaels.com you
can follow me there for free you can
also get 10% off if you pay your
membership by the year if you pay your
membership by the year if you want to
support the show to keep my microphone
on and keep the power going and keep my
voice on I know it's a little strain
this morning but it's gonna get better I
promise and you know I'll do the show
rather I've got a voice or
not who needs a voice when you're doing
a radio show right don't go anywhere I'm
gon to get a cough drop and a drink of
water I'll be right back
right after this stick around don't
touch that dial as they say on the
radio what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reached DC weight was 50 strong and
number some patriots ran out of gas
along the way we got plenty of slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again yours Bob dear Bob I'm fixing
to send you some more of them Doritos
you like the red bag not the live loving
blue one in your absence I discovered a
rash on my neck and no it ain't no
hickey and I ain't even seen my cousin
bro in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast
welcome back to the
show oh man that boys
[Music]
huh we got all kinds of lies and
deception in politics today I've got
some clips I want to show you um I
promise they're all going to be great G
to be good I want to show you um some
religious
Clips oh
boy these religious nuts out there it's
getting crazy um I want to show you the
cult I gotta show you this this video of
trump saying
that he says we've been Waging allout
War on American democracy do you
remember you remember the um the clip
that Mitt Romney tried to use against
Obama in
2012 you didn't build if you got a
business you didn't build that you
remember that they took it totally out
of context he was talking about roads
and bridges and [__] he's like look if
you have if you got a the roads and
bridges and [__] that your business uses
to do
business if you got a business you
didn't build that you pay taxes and the
government built that that's how it
works or you or you got out of paying
taxes because you put Republican
politicians in power and they made it to
where you didn't have to [__] pay
taxes so you let middle class Americans
and lower class Americans pay taxes to
build the roads that you make your
profits on you know that sort of [__]
that's kind of what Obama sentiment was
but they totally flew over their heads
and they took it out of context now this
isn't out of context because I believe
that this guy this guy believes this and
he's just saying it we've been Waging
allout War on American democracy because
they have
been
like every [__] day they can't stop I
mean it's
insanity and then and then the
hypocrites Al George Santos last week
from the House of Representatives they
expel him which is hilarious I think
it's funny I mean I think it's dumb too
like this is stupid like why did we
waste our time getting rid of this guy
this guy was gone anyways and really
he's not gone now he's doing some
[__] HBO movie I guess I guess HBO is
gonna do a movie about um George Santos
starring Anthony devolder that's the
narrative I'm going with I don't give a
[__] but also he's outing Republican
members of Congress so you know what
there's always there's always a shining
a shining diamond in the rough right so
was a silver lining here and the silver
lining of them outing George
Santos is that George Santos is gonna
out these people the only thing I want
to know from George
Santos
is how is it that Andy
ogles of Tennessee and how is it that
the Speaker of the
House Mike
Johnson doesn't have a [__] bank
account have you heard this this is real
[__] now this is Phil Williams um now
this is a pretty long report but I think
it's worth doing and the reason why I
think it's worth doing here on the show
on
Andy ogles number one because Andy ogles
is a lying piece of [__] I mean he is a
republican so you know a [__]
s but also I think it's worth doing and
the reason why is
because it seems that the Speaker of the
House Mike Johnson has been engaged in a
lot of the same activity that Andy ogles
has and I believe
that George Santos outing his Republican
colleagues I don't maybe maybe just
maybe maybe just maybe he would know how
this whole I don't have checking account
scam works I would bet if someone knows
if someone knows how this I don't have
checking account scammed works and I
loaned my campaign
$320,000 that I didn't have if anyone
knows how that works it's probably
Anthony devolder oh excuse me George
Santos but let's watch Philly Williams
report here on Andy
ogal Andy ogal devolder let's
watch tonight News Channel 5
investigates follows the money involving
middle Tennessee's newest member of
Congress but instead of finding answers
that investigation turns up even more
questions about Andy ogles good evening
to you I'm Carrie sharp and I'm Rory
Johnston among those questions where did
ogles get
$320,000 that he claims to have loaned
campaign our chief investigative
reporter Phil Williams has been
searching for that answer Phil okay now
you guys know Phil Williams like he was
you know um on stepen coar he was the
one that exposed uh what's her name um
what's that [__] naz's name she was
running for
mayor
um Gabrielle Hansen that's it Gabrielle
Hansen um she was the she was the one
pounding around with the Nazis got her
[__] ass kicked in the Merl race she
was a city council woman who was an
outright Nazi hanging out with them you
using them uh to to attack her opponents
in town who were speaking out against
her campaign and her as mayor listen and
Cynthia says ogles is another Santos but
they're just Republicans I mean
Cynthia they're just Republicans right
am I right I mean they're just [__]
Republicans but yeah ogles is another
Santos Mike Johnson is another ogles but
they're all they're all it's all the
party of Santos isn't it if you get
right down to it that's why they really
were really cautious and why no
leadership voted to expel George Santos
did you know that no Republican
Mike Johnson didn't either I think the
reason why Mike Johnson didn't vote to
expel George Santos is because George
Santos knows how the checking account
scam works but let's see if we can
figure out Phil Williams if he figures
out how the loaning my campaign
$320,000 that I don't have Works see if
we can figure out this scam what makes
this question so intriguing is one Andi
ogos has never been seen as a person of
great wealth on top of that now that
he's in Congress he has not disclosed
any substantial Investments he doesn't
even report having a checking account I
can tell you that did you hear
that the speaker of the house is the
same one
right now I must be off my [__]
rocker
here I must be missing something I mean
I have personal checking accounts I have
business checking accounts I have
savings accounts I mean who doesn't have
a [__] bank account right I mean
there's some people out there that don't
have bank accounts because they don't
trust the
bank and they do pay their bills with
like U uh uh uh money orders and [__]
but godamn that's few and far between
anymore there isn't that many people
that do that anymore [__] you got to
have like a PayPal account or something
right gez or venmo or something
goddamn not
one not
one checking account that's [__]
weird Andy it really is the thing is it
isn't that weird in Republican politics
because Mike Johnson also does not
report of having a checking account I
can tell you that we have a problem at
the border from the beginning of Andy
yle's 2022 campaign for congress the
Murray County Republican was dogged by
questions about his fundraising claims
with even conservative media noting he
was three days late filing his first
campaign Finance report then six days
late still not filing it seven days past
the filing deadline talk radio was
skeptical of Ogle's excuses there were
quote issues retrieving bank records
you're kidding me I that's not a
credible statement issues retrieving
bank statements I mean this is the this
is 2022 ogles had kicked off his
campaign claiming he had raised
$453,000 in the first 30 days but when
the report was eventually filed he had
raised far less only
$254,000 oh so he's a [__] liar
huh huh well godamn you know I've been
yelling and screaming that George Santos
isn't [__] an outlier
he's just a republican
folks what what the [__] do you want
he's just a [__] crook and most of
the time in our day and age the people
who are going to commit [__] crooked
[__] schemes here is the ones who who
have the knowledge of the griffs and the
ones that seem to have the best griffs
about them are the right I mean the
entire right-wing apparatus is a is a
big [__]
grift I mean Jesus Christ just looking
moms for Liberty they're raising money
to stop people from having homosexual
relationships and they're having
homosexual relationships in
threesoms come on
man come on SO Andy Ogle's being a liar
well [__] that's on brand for
Republicans isn't it especially when
you're lying about money huh Santos
still OG also reported he personally
loaned his campaign
$320,000 supposedly giving himself a
formidable W chess huh I wonder where
Andy ogles got the 320 Grand either a he
doesn't have 320 Grand and he didn't
give himself 320 Grand it's a [__]
lie which is a complete [__]
possibility because he is a Republican
or B he got it from someone who has a
sign copy of mine C down in his library
in Texas possibly someone like that you
know I don't know if there was such a
person that
existed right come on I'm not that far
off the I'm not I don't got my tinf hat
on I can't be this crazy when you got
people in Texas who have sign copies of
mine comp that they [__] brag about
and their personal Library giving money
to buy Supreme Court
Justices giving money to [__]
Democratic candidates and and third
party candidates to run to take away
votes from Joe Biden you don't think
that that a [__] like that or
someone you know in that ilk isn't gonna
[__] shoot someone like Andy Ogle 320
Grand but where would they put it where
did where did Andy get 320
Grand he ain't even got a [__]
checking account man he ain't even got a
checking account and you got 320 Grand
would you have it buried in the [__]
backyard
[__] I think the biggest
question is where did this money come
from yeah clear from his financial
disclosure reports where he got the
money for this loan Daniel Caputo works
for the Washington Watchdog group The
Campaign Legal Center we had pulled
Ogle's personal financial disclosures
which are required by law listing assets
that included an investment property as
well as three retirement accounts held
by ogles and his wife missing from
Ogle's report is any reference to any
bank accounts or other assets of more
than $1,000 which must be disclosed so
it definitely raises you know big
questions as to where did that money
come from and how was he able to loan it
uh because currently his financial
disclosure reports are not showing that
sort of wealth that he could easily lend
that money I will not be resigning it's
a transparency issue that has been
highlighted by their George Santos case
a recent indictment accuses the New York
Congressman of falsely reporting that he
had loaned his committee significant
sums of money when he had not made the
reported loans and in fact did not have
the funds necessary to make such loans
at the time he did it the indictment
says for the purpose of making the
committee appear more financially sound
than it was or for Watch Dogs like
yourself is there any way to tell where
this money came
from um currently no um so it definitely
begs the question of of you know is
there something that's just missing from
the financial disclosure report um is
there something that we'll see later um
maybe he just forgot to include it on
the other oh yeah he just forgot to
include it
yeah just a clerical error like George
Santos is going to try to argue in court
that all the money he stole off credit
cards is just clerical errors a yeah
that money is just a clerical
error all right
yeah I bet here's the thing here's the
thing and here's why this is so
important folks is because it ain't just
George Santos doing this it ain't just
Andy ogles doing this folks these people
seeking power and try to legislate at
the highest levels of government trying
to tell us what the [__] to
do they're doing it and they're and they
want to keep their positions so they can
do this kind of [__] that Annie ogles is
doing cuz it's all about appearing to be
rich I mean think about it their orange
mango musolini Jesus his entire
personality is to pretend to be
rich that's why he's [__] in New York
in this Civil
Trial when tis James cuts down the Trump
organization like a fresh cut
tree that's going to prevent Donald
Trump from pretending to be a
billionaire
that he's not and he's never
been speaking of that Donald Trump said
over the weekend that that Joe Biden's
to and the Biden family took five
billion with a B five billion dollars
that means that that Biden has a bigger
net wealth than Donald Trump I'm just
letting all MAA know if you're voting
for Trump because he's some kind of Rich
businessman you might want to consider
voting for Biden because apparently the
Republicans have found where Biden made
$5 billion that's crazy [__] but let's
continue with Andy Ogle's Financial
crimes it looks like hand Ogle's
personal financial disclosure show loans
that include a home mortgage from
Interfirst and a line of credit from
Bank Corp South property records showed
that line of credit was dropped but we
discovered documents showing another
line of credit taken out last year from
First Bank that listed his in-laws on
the note for a total of $700,000
ogul did not disclose that loan on his
personal financial disclosure so this
seems to be a pretty big um question
mark as to why it it was not included in
his financial disclosure report because
there doesn't seem to be any reason why
it was not so how did you forget what
your major was in college this all
follows questions raised earlier this
year by News Channel 5 investigates
about how ogles inflated his educational
credentials and business experience
Congressman this doesn't have to be a
story if you can just offer
some evidence it went for a good cause
then we uncovered evidence about a
GoFundMe where oakles raised money for a
children's burial Garden that was never
built Wrecking in almost
$25,000 hey I've heard this story before
where someone starts a gofund me to help
someone get their you know their their
dog back or a dog because their dog
passed away so they're trying to get
them a a service dog and they raise a
bunch of money it wasn't anywhere near
$23,000 and it feels like that's what
kicked off their their Federal
indictment was the story about raising
money for dogs H I wonder what that
person's name is I wonder what how that
person's feeling right now I wonder I
wonder why I wonder why this isn't uh I
wonder why this story and because
Cynthia says why isn't this a bigger
story that's why I'm covering it because
folks this is much bigger than [__]
George Santos this is much bigger than
[__] Anthony O Anthony Andy ogal
devolder or Anthony ogal deer either way
yeah sure because folks Mike Johnson
reportedly doesn't have a personal
checking
account the speaker of the [__]
house there is some kind of scam that
these
Republicans are doing and They're
copying it from person to person to
person
how the [__] couldn't it be dude they're
doing the same [__] I told you I told
you told you this George Santos is not
an
outlier he's not an outlier he just
loves all the [__] Republican lies he
loves them all he loves them all and
apparently he loves all the Republican
scams and he loves money too I mean you
know let's be frank cuz with money comes
power these people believe ogles has not
released any evidence of what he did
with the money the public has a right to
know uh what your financial obligations
are as for the questions about the money
that ogul supposedly loaned his own
campaign and the line of credit he felt
to disclose no there's definitely uh I
think a lot more questions are raised by
these Financial disclosure reports than
are answered by
them so how does Andy ogles explain any
of this well we just don't know I sent
an email to his office even texted his
personal cell phone asking if he would
show us evidence that what he has
reported is true but unfortunately he
has not
responded I wonder what it could be I
wonder if there isn't
evidence of him having 320 Grand other
than other than he used a line of credit
in his [__] in-law's name to give
himself campaign Finance so his F so his
campaign look like they had money so he
could become a member of
Congress Jennifer says here on YouTube
he's a fraud like Santos they're all
frauds like Santos Jennifer all of them
all the [__] Republicans every
[__] last one of them it's all a
fraud it's all a
grift the entire [__] the whole the
whole [__]
apparatus I mean even even Ronda santis
think about this Ronda santis was vly
against Disney Disney cuz Disney was
grooming kids with their with their
lgbtq content and then his wife goes out
on stage and admits that their children
watch Disney
movies he doesn't believe they they they
really don't believe this [__] it's all
for money it's all for grift it's all to
get the [__] sheep it's sheep food
that's right it's all for money every
last bit of it they're just counting
[__]
money I I know to some degree I wish the
left wing would do this why not I mean
I'd make a lot more [__] money hell
if I could make this a Griff machine
[__] [__] yeah I mean that would be
great if someone paid me just to tell
you what you wanted to hear that'd be
[__]
awesome I'd never do
it I would never I don't I don't I don't
know how much money it would take to
convince me I mean maybe there's a
number maybe there's a number but I I
feel like I feel like the principle of
democracy is a hell lot more important
than any kind of amount of money or any
kind of amount of power that you'd get
in government Jesus [__] Christ these
[__]
scumbags I mean it's just it it just
doesn't end with these some
[__] now Phil Williams with Channel 5
News does a fantastic job and they were
talking about this in the producers
Corner this morning uh you guys know
that we do a patreon thing on Monday
mornings and Friday mornings an hour
before the show and if you didn't know
go to the Tony michaels.com join patreon
join the $20 tier and then join the
Discord and you guys can come in and
talk to us in the producers Corner
listen to us we just had one big
conversation it's not like the show it's
just it's just like a meeting that we're
just talking to each other and talking
about different issues and stuff a lot
of it ends up on the show because you
guys are [__] smart and you guys
bring to the table a lot of things like
Deedra this morning was talking about
that the the the the the Texas go voted
to let the Texas GOP hang out with Nazis
it's okay hang out with Nazis like Nick
quentes no big deal We're Not Gonna
condemn it if you want to hang out with
Nazis hang out with Nazis we're okay
with it they literally did that [__]
that's right they voted they voted in
favor of the Texas GOP to hang out with
Nazis and white supremacists I'm not
[__] you Jan asked where small rat
is oh rat's here let's see where's rat
rat are you here oh there you are
there's rat he's mining still looks like
he's still mining he's in the laboratory
don't worry rat's always in the in the
background where do you think those
noises came
from CH Ching CH Ching CH Ching CH Ching
he he's back there causing trouble in
the laboratory don't worry rat's here
he's always here we're always causing
some kind of trouble good
trouble but
trouble um zny was wondering what
organization did this report it's Phil
Williams of u nc5
news there in um they in Nashville
Tennessee Phil Williams is the one who
uncovered
Gabrielle Hansen's campaign and how she
piled around with Nazis now there's more
reporting uh to this um there is uh let
me see if I can pull it up here there's
another report and this is this is from
a while back on Andy ogles I believe
this is um from I don't know um several
weeks ago but listen to this one on Andy
ogles see if you can see any any
Republican on brand traits than Andy
ogles has if you believe middle
Tennessee's newest Congressman he's not
only a businessman he's also an
economist a trained law enforcement
officer even an expert in international
sex crimes but yeah he's he's none of
those he's none of those as this report
shows and that's the
point is that they're [__] Liars I've
been telling you this there's no reason
to expel George
Santos because if you expel George
Santos for the [__] you expel them for
you have to expel all of them all the
Republicans have to go all of them all
of them including the speaker including
Andy ogles listen to this [__] but an
exclusive News Channel 5 investigation
discovered Andy Ogle's life story may
not be nearly as dramatic as he
sometimes make it makes it sound our
chief investigative reporter Phil
Williams has been checking into this and
this questionable resume he has abs I
love Doug here on
YouTube Doug said money isn't a crime no
it's money isn't a
crime
it [__] defrauding people for money
stealing money lying about money when
you're supposed to have legal
disclosures of money because you're a
member of Congress that's a crime hey
Doug that's a crime it can be
man listen absolutely Andy ogles
represents the newly redrawn fifth
congressional district which includes
parts of Davidson County as well as
Williamson Murray Marshall and Lewis
after the Saga involving George Santos
we decided to take a look at the Murray
County Republican and discovered a story
that is sometimes not what it seems the
house will be in order not long after
his election to
Congress freshman Andy ogles felt
himself in the middle of the drama over
the house speakers sorry I misre Doug's
statement money it's a crime yes it is a
crime thanks Doug sorry about
that I'm little off my game must be the
cough drops yeah you know so I'm an
economist giving the Tennessee
Republican a chance to introduce himself
to a national audience what do you want
to serve on well so I'm an economist it
was a claim I'm an economist I worked in
economics in healthcare ogles had made
on the campaign Trail you know as an
economist I can tell you and repeated in
his first meeting of the house Financial
Services committee you know as an
economist yet like some of the questions
surrounding his controversial colleague
New York Congressman George Santos
there's little evidence that ogal ever
received any formal training in
economics his Congressional bio says he
obtained a degree from Middle Tennessee
State University where he studied policy
and economics yet the school refused to
confirm Ogle's degree citing a provision
of federal law that allows students to
BL block the release of their
educational credentials which made me
curious about why why would Congressman
ogles not want Tennessee voters to be
able to verify that he is who he says he
is and so I would think if he has a
block that there must be something wrong
Democrat Heidi Campbell who lost to ogal
in a campaign in a district that
Republicans redrew to help their own
candidate had the same reaction in
response to our questions ogles released
this image of a diploma for a b Bor of
Science degree from Middle Tennessee
State in 2007 when he was 36 but what we
discovered next WoW surprise the
candidate ogul defeated oh my gosh it
was a resume from two years after he
graduated where he listed a degree in
international relations with minors in
psychology and English and likewise on
this form for a background check in his
own writing no mention of Economics I
mean that looks to me like somebody who
um doesn't have any background in
economics again Andy ogles is a [__]
liar but is it surprising to
you I mean seeing what we saw with
George Santos and and listen the only
reason why the only reason why George
Santos is a standout is because George
Santos he liked all the lies he liked
all the griffs he wanted to do all of
them he wanted at all in Republican
politics most people even greedy people
have a a point where they're like well I
don't want to expose myself and George
Santos loved the
spotlight he loved the spotlight he
loved to talk and run his mouth like
Trump and talk his way into indictments
like that's what George Santos did Andy
ogles doesn't do that Andy ogles runs
from reporters he won't answer he won't
send you [__]
evidence where is George Santos couldn't
keep his [__] mouth shut he had the
right to remain silent just not the
[__] ability like Trump why does that
say about his
claims uh you know I'm not surprised I'm
I I think that if you really dig in to
him and and what he's done you're
probably gonna find that there's a lot
more where this came from the
congressman's website also calls ogles a
nationally recognized expert on tax
policy and Health Care having been
featured in numerous Publications
including the Wall Street Journal and
Investors Business Daily but a search of
those sites shows only three columns he
wrote two of them with another person
when he was a lobbyist for the
conservative Americans for
Prosperity oh Andy ogles is a lobbyist H
so not an
economist not someone who's an expert on
International sex
trafficking okay because you were a
sheriff's deputy [__] out of here they
get into that
too but now now the [__] claims
that he was featured in some um kind of
[__] Publications he's just one of
the names on the article on the oped
okay nothing independently citing him as
an expert it might be a bit more
credible if a new source had called him
and said you know quoted him on the
basis that he was a national expert mty
isue political science professor John B
says the publication of those columns
like this one predicting the imminent
demise of Obamacare might not have that
much to do with Ogle's personal
credentials uh Jan here says how about
some vetting the problem is Jan if if
Republicans vetted themselves they
wouldn't have anyone running they're
they they wouldn't have anyone running
like who would they have in the race if
they vetted these people I mean Andy
ogal was the best of the worst of them
that's the [__] story is Andy ogles
was the best of the [__] on the
Republican side that's the [__]
that's the truth of it Andy Ogle's
[__] opponents in the primary and the
Republican primary in his district were
worse than
him so I mean vetting I'm I'm all for
Republicans vetting because then they
wouldn't be able to run anybody because
they're all [__] frauds when you
publish an article like this and it's
under the name of your
organization you might be publishing as
much because it reflects the views of
the organization as because it reflects
the particular expertise of the writer
as a former member of law enforcement
Works in international sex crimes
specifically child traffing then there
are Ogle's claims you know my mid life
crisis into law enforcement specifically
I right but I work for traffing to be an
international sex crimes expert this is
from firsthand experience for someone
who worked in that space I turned gray
because of it he literally has that on
his
um on his website that he's a
international sex crimes
expert I
mean I'm not going to say maybe that
title you know has some projection in it
but I mean how else do you become an
international sex crimes expert let's
listen to his his theory in fact we
discovered ogles was sworn in as a
volunteer Reserve Deputy with the
Williamson County Sheriff's Office in
July 2009 a position he lost two years
later for not meeting minimum standards
making no progress in filled training
and failure to attend required meetings
Jesus Christ sh spokesperson says there
is nothing in Mr Ogle's training or
personnel file that indicates he had any
involvement in international sex
trafficking in his capacity as a reserve
Deputy so he was a
volunteer Reserve Deputy so that way
this [__] bonehead could claim that
he had expertise in international sex
trafficking
listen I'm not saying Andy ogles does
doesn't have expertise in international
sex trafficking he is a republican okay
he is a Republican and he goes to
churches and he claims to be Christian
so I'm not gonna
claim that Andy ogles doesn't have
expertise on International sex
trafficking the problem is is it doesn't
appear that his expertise on
International sex trafficking comes from
his time as a [__] [__]
volunteer Deputy Reserve Deputy for a
sheriff's department I don't know if you
guys know this like if you go to your
local sheriff's department they
literally are like yes if you want to be
a reserve a volunteer Reserve Deputy we
will welcome you like as long as you can
pass the [__] the you know the
minimum
bar of of qualifications they'll totally
let you be a volunteer Reserve Deputy
they don't have to pay
you they don't have to pay
you but how the [__] how the [__] does
Andy ogles have international sex
trafficking
expertise as his time as a reserve
volunteer Reserve Deputy when the guy
couldn't even meet minimum standards for
[__] showing up at meetings and
training
I wonder my question to Andy ogles would
be where does your expertise of
international sex trafficking come from
because it clearly doesn't come from
your law enforcement experience which is
nothing so where does that International
sex trafficking experience and expertise
come from Andy I began working
volunteering my time ogles did some work
in 2011 for abolition International a
nonprofit founded by gospel artist Grant
his Congressional website claims ogal
was responsible for overseeing
operations and investments in 12
countries and then I ended up becoming
Chief Operating Officer and it was just
one of those I didn't really intend to
set out to be so heavily involved in the
fight against human trafficking it just
kind of occurred and privately people
associated with a group dispute Ogle's
characterization of his role in fact the
group's tax return show ogles held a
part-time position that paid him a grand
total of of
$4,000
man seems like he was getting paid a lot
of money to be a
full-time International sex crimes
expert okay this is another [__]
grift another [__] grift that's
that's what this is it's another [__]
grift they go around to church church
church and they talk about sex
trafficking and children child sex
trafficking and they raise a bunch of
money and then they pay you a bunch of
dumb [__] who were who are
going to be become Republican
politicians so they can claim that
they're [__] experts on International
sex crimes and actually what they're
[__] experts on is going and stealing
[__] church members
money that's what they're [__]
experts on is stealing people's
money yeah 100% keep going $4,000
$4,000 yeah wow I mean that just does
not sound to me like somebody who was
the COO and an archived version of the
group's website shows it was making
grants to holistic Ministries in just a
handful of countries not 12 countries
and certainly not busting International
sex Rings If this information had come
out would it have made any
difference yeah I think it might
of my election's over and and and I've
moved on and that's fine but I do think
going forward people need to to know who
they're
electing we have even more on our
website of course we reached out to
Congressman Ogle's office laying out our
findings giving him a chance to tell us
if he thought we got anything wrong but
just like he avoided the media during
the campaign we never heard back of
course you didn't Phil of course you
didn't because if Annie ogles replyed
back he would end up in a self-d demise
like George Santos and why the [__] why
the where's the [__] Republicans that
called for George Santos and voted for
George Santos to be expelled why aren't
they gone for Andy ogles to be expelled
and if we run down this road of
[__] that don't have checking
accounts you ain't got a personal
checking account how the [__] do you pay
your bills
[__] you going down to the the the the
post office at the grocery store and
getting money orders for your bills Mike
Johnson because Mike Johnson ain't got
no [__] personal checking accounts
either and that's a big question we
should be asking why in the [__] why in
the [__] is that that weirdo Mike
Johnson who's got a goddamn Christian
porn app so he can trade porn with his
underage son why does that [__]
not have a checking account and why is
he the speaker of the
house and why did he vote to keep George
Santos
h Huh huh all this goes hand inand and
I'm glad that Phil
um thank God for people like Phil
Williams who stay on these stories like
this and I know it feels like Tony is
this is this a real story listen in the
next year Andy ogles is gonna be a big
story Andy ogles is gonna be a big story
and because the Republicans did what
they did with George Santos they're gon
to have to do what they did to George
Santos to Andy ogles
and on and on it will
go and this is the stupid [__] thing
that they opened up this is the
Pandora's Box that Republicans opened
up and I believe it's a big Pandora's
Box that that Democrats opened up
too another Pandora's Box that
Republicans Just Can't Stop
opening speaking of Mike Johnson and
Pandora's boxes
we have to thank Mike Johnson really
honestly no he's no listen listen he's
doing good Mike Johnson is doing a lot
of good because he's listening to people
like Marjorie Taylor green and releasing
the January 6 tapes this is the best
[__] thing th I I tell you I tell you
what this is the best policy that these
[__] right-wing Maga trumpers have
ever had this is the best one out of all
of them like they always [__] the bed on
these things
they have such dumb [__] ideas such
dumb policies like even when they start
out with something good it ends up just
to be a pile of [__] you know what I
mean Trump's like oh no we're gonna get
rid of the ACA and we'll have something
much better in two weeks and two weeks
has been [__] eight years right am I
right they always [__] the bed but this
January six tape release those that all
the tapes that's the best [__] thing
that's happened
because here here's the thing Theo
Hansen NEP NEP Napa Idaho was
apprehended in charge for his ACS
January
6 because they released Mike Johnson
released the tapes there is [__]
insurrectionist after insurrectionist
after insurrectionist being
arrested so I mean to some
degree I mean you know this isn't their
intent and this isn't trying to how
they're trying to sell it oh you should
see the right-wing influencers online
they're totally ignoring the fact that
the FBI is using the Sedition hunters
and online slle to find these [__]
people because Mike Johnson is releasing
these tapes that's why Mike Johnson
keeps is slow walking this [__] is
because Mike Johnson is putting his
[__] supporters in
jail and you want me to be mad about
that [__] that
[__] hell when when they had this idea
when Marjorie Taylor green and all these
other [__] chuckleheads were out
there like yeah let's release the tapes
let's release the truth and Kevin
McCarthy's like yeah but that'll arrest
more Trump supporters and like oh you
got to do it anyways or we'll get rid of
you so he's like well I'll give a few of
them to Tucker Carlson and let Tucker
Carlson produce some
propaganda so that no one gets arrested
and they did that thing and they still
weren't satisfied because these [__]
chuckleheads are never satis
satisfied they're never
satisfied
ever they can never seek total
satisfaction it's the reason why they're
going to lose with roie
Wade they won that point they destroyed
roie Wade and then they were like oh no
we're really gonna go balls
deep we're going to totally totally
[__] obl
literate women's
rights now I want to show you a
a a report here from
CNN speaking of January Sixers and the
tapes that are coming
out the reason why and again this isn't
going to get much [__] traction it's
not going to get much
traction now I was talking about Liz
Cheney and the a block and everyone you
know gets kind of upset or gets kind of
weirded out when I'm speaking out
against Liz Cheney when Liz Cheney is
saying the [__] we want to hear I don't
care if Liz Cheney is saying the [__] we
want to hear right now I go based on who
[__] Liz Cheney is and who she shown
us to
be and that you have to look through
that [__] lens when Liz Cheney says
[__] and again Liz Cheney really owes
the email lady an apology because she's
not saying anything that [__] Hillary
Clinton wasn't saying in 2016 the only
thing she's not doing is apologizing to
the country for what the [__] she
did Liz Cheney owes us an
apology she owes America an
apology for elevating this [__]
wannabe
dictator when she knew it she knew it
but if you want to see how someone
actually does this thing where they
repent against
trumpism and their love for Trump and
how they were part of the
cult here you go Pam Hempel is among the
many who participated in the January 6th
Insurrection she served two months in
federal prison for her role in the riot
and Pam Hempel joins me right now thank
you for being here uh can you tell us
what is your reaction to this ruling no
immunity from for Trump from civil suits
do you plan on suing in light of
this
absolutely yes okay so Pam Hill here was
a trump supporter she actually went to
the January 6
Insurrection okay she served like I
think I think it was six months in
prison she served prison time for Trump
okay she prison time for him this lady
has [__] come out and said you know I
was ridiculous for even believing this
[__] I can't believe I was dup but I
was LZ jany hasn't said that [__] not
once not once as Liz Cheney say she was
duped by Trump because she wasn't duped
by Trump she knew who Trump was the
whole [__] time she knew who he
was she knew who who he was was she knew
what he was capable of Pam Hill here was
not Pam Hill here probably watched Fox
News and was looking at Facebook and was
was duped into supporting
Trump was duped into believing lies so
much so that she went to be an
insurrectionist and paid the price for
it but
listen yeah um I was stumbled on and
trampled on they pulled my shoulder cut
my knee if it wasn't for the capitol
police officers I I would be
dead and Trump is
responsible if you were to sue do you
worry about the backlash from his
supporters maybe people you even know
because you were among them at one
point no not when you're doing the right
thing I it backlash doesn't bother me
I've already gotten enough already so no
that wouldn't bother me at
all so while all of this is going on you
know former president Trump he's facing
multiple criminal trials but in spite of
it all he is the front runner in the
Republican presidential race right now
you were such a strong supporter at a
certain point that you were at the
capital it landed you in jail do you
have a sense of what keeps people so
loyal to him and what it might take for
them to change their minds as you
did
well as a lot of people are starting to
recognize Trump is a cult leader he
turned Mega into a cult and so they're
listening to he gas lights them and
gives them out a lot of lies he first he
started with the love bombing and he
keeps doing that but actually I don't
think we need to be afraid of of trump
as much as we need to be afraid of the
Republican party if you're familiar with
2020 I mean sorry
2025 uh project
2025 that's what you need to be afraid
of because whoever becomes president the
party now wants to have a dictator in
there and uh we're going to lose our
democracy you said earlier that you
believe that Trump is
responsible what is it in your view that
he did that makes him culpable for what
happened on January
6th well he knew the election wasn't
stolen and why is he having and
everybody go down to the capital see
when I got there there was the crowd was
so big I couldn't get through so I
walked around and asked what else was
going on that day and they said I think
I heard Trump's going to be at the
capital okay so you hear
that do you hear the plan that was laid
out and Pam M was talking about it she
served 60 days in jail sorry I said six
months 60 I got six 60 confused I was
wrong oh Tony was wrong oh my God
yeah I was wrong 60 days she still went
to jail though for 60 days but did you
hear what she said she went to the
capital to support him he had this all
planned to get them there and get them
riled up because he knew if he got them
there and get them riled up they'd do
anything especially if he was gonna go
to the
capital folks there were people on the
ground at January 6 that knew Donald
Trump's plan the oathkeepers the proud
boys you know how they you know how
these [__] idiots are trying to say
that oh the FBI is the one who got the
crowd all riled up they were the ones
trying to get the crowd all riled up
that's all
[__] that's all [__] [__] it
was it was Trump and his allies that
were planned on getting that that crowd
ril up to go to the [__] capital and
do what they
did watch what she says this is [__]
this is super important and as I'm
walking there I'm thinking well why are
we going to the capital he just had a
talk so I feel like he had it all
planned that he wanted the people to
attack the capital that's just my
feeling but um no he's responsible
because he said March down there he
tries to use peacefully no he said go
fight like hell is what he said and and
this is someone Pam who believed him she
believed him at the time cuz she she in
the crowd she believes Trump she
believes he's the cult leader he's the
great one it's been stolen from him and
she's got a fight like
hell she heard what he said she acted on
what he said she's telling us she's
telling us folks he was talking to the
wrong people because they took that
literally do you think that Trump will
ultimately face any consequences for his
actions whether they're legal or
Criminal
I believe so I think we can have a lot
of faith in in Jack Smith he knows what
he's doing he's got the receipts you
know and I think that's it's sadly we're
going to have to wait till court for
people to start realizing that Trump is
lied about everything and Trump is a
criminal and he needs to have his day in
court to be proven what we're already
know that he he's a criminal he knows it
so there's Pam Mill now what's the
difference between this and Liz Cheney
Tony what's the difference the
difference is is Pam hemp Hill is not
someone who was steeped in politics she
wasn't a leader of the Republican
Congressional
caucus Pam hemp Hill was believing [__]
that was posted on
Facebook
okay she was believing [__] that was
post on Facebook I have family
members who are part of this cult who
believe leave this [__] that's posted on
Facebook it's [__] wild and nutty and
crazy why do you think I'm here every
day speaking out against
this but Pam hemp pill for whatever
reason some people in the chat are
saying it's because of jail or the
consequences but she clearly understood
what was happening that day at this
point and as soon as she could she
speaks out against
Trump Cheney knew who Trump was the
entire time the entire [__] time the
whole time let me show you let me show
you the [__] I'll show you the
[__] video evidence of it I'm gonna
show it to you here that they're doing a
report this morning Savannah Guth on and
and a lot of people have been and I know
some people in the chat say hey Tony no
one here likes Liz I know but people
online when I [__] speak out against
it and I tweet it they get all [__]
bent out of shape that I'm [__]
speaking out against Liz chainu and I
don't give a [__] I care less I care
less if you if you get your [__] butt
hurt because I gonna tell the truth
about Liz Cheney I'm gonna tell you the
[__] truth whether you like it or not
I don't give a [__] if you don't like
the truth fine that that's fine I don't
give a [__] I'm still gonna tell it to
you because listen to this
here of Liz Cheney talking to Savannah
GTH
okay listen no time for pleasantries
after I read this book you said in the
starkest terms we will be voting on
whether to preserve our Republic in the
next election you think this is a vote
about whether or not we still have
democracy in this country it's
it's book book book bu the book by the
book by the book by the [__] book
huh right right buy the book
I don't if you know who Liz Cheney's dad
is and I don't know if you know that why
Liz Cheney is who she is Liz Cheney is
who she is because of nepotism she's a
nepo political baby is what the [__] she
is regardless of how you want to twist
it and turn it and all that [__] she's a
neppo
baby it's the truth but give us give us
what Liz Cheney stands some democracy is
democracy in this country it certainly
is you know and and Donald Trump has
told us exactly what he will do he will
not abide by the rulings of the courts
uh he uh will certainly appoint people
to office whether or not they can be
confirmed by the Senate uh okay this is
all stupid those two things those two
points that she just made are points
that Hillary Clinton was
making he was saying that [__] in
[__]
he was saying that [__]
then I mean don't make me pull the
[__] tape but he was saying that [__]
then where was she where was she on this
principle okay if this really truly is
her principal because we didn't hear Pam
Hill say any of this [__] right that's
not that's not how Pam Hill came to this
conclusion if Liz Cheney in
politics in Republican party as
leadership leadership in the house
caucus didn't hear him saying this [__]
and didn't come this collusion how smart
is she really but let's continue um he
has talked about using the military uh
in terms that uh really are
fundamentally unamerican another another
thing he did in a very dangerous and
it's a moment for people and not be the
path that we go down as a country just
yesterday oh oh so now it's now it's not
a path
before when it suited her power interest
because that's truly what it is folks
the reason why Liz Cheney hates Trump is
because her power
interest is at
stake her power interest is at
stake that's why she's [__] selling
this [__] [__] you pay me for the
book she wants you to buy the book so
she can make profit off her [__]
shitty
decisions that she made you didn't did
you vote for Trump did you vote for
Trump twice did you as a member of
Congress stand back and just vote and
vote and vote and vote for
Trump did you support him after the
20120 election he had
lost and as leadership didn't say a
[__] thing in your in your official
capacity that he had lost for 190 days
did you or did you not
today in an interview you said
fundamentally there's a choice to be
made you can't be both for Donald Trump
and for the Constitution you have to
choose yeah a vote for Donald Trump is
unconstitutional
anti-American oh oh LZ Cheney now cares
about the Constitution so that would
lead me to believe that she cares about
people's rights and [__] and she
doesn't Time After Time After Time
example after example after for example
Liz Cheney doesn't give a [__] about the
Constitution Liz Cheney [__]
supported Donald Trump in the Impe in
the first
impeachment when he was trying to
[__]
blackmail the new president of
Ukraine and using government fun funding
in that blackmail for his own personal
campaign to have Ukraine do
investigations into Joe Biden [__]
that's what they're doing now and Liz
Cheney saying it's the worst thing on
Earth that they're doing and she was
doing it
then she's a [__] wolf in sheep's
clothing I don't give a [__] how you
twist it I don't care how you [__]
think it's great that Liz Chene is
saying this
[__] if she does not admit the
truth and she does not repent as you
want to call it and apologize to America
for the [__] she did that she's telling
us not to do she's telling us not to do
the [__] she did and she won't even
[__] apologize for
it she just wants us to buy her [__]
book well [__] me
running and you expect me to look at the
TRU truth and not be pissed off about
this get the [__] out of here with this
[__] this [__] [__] where I
have to be aligned with this scumbag
piece of [__] [__] no [__] way am
I ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever gonna line with some
[__] scumbag piece of [__] like this
no [__] way she is anti [__]
democracy she does not believe in
Liberal [__] values she does not
believe people should the same [__]
rights as everyone else she doesn't
[__] believe it she is doesn't
believe in the Constitution she wants
her own [__] fascist interpretation
of the Constitution I don't give a [__]
if she's against Trump or for Trump I
don't give a
[__] we cannot we
cannot act like she is part of our
liberal [__] Coalition she's not just
like Chris christe's not you do I I how
many times I brought Chris Christie
Clips up and like yeah great Chris
Christie's pointing out this thing he's
doing a great job but [__] him but [__]
him we cannot get on the side of these
fascist
folks this thin veil [__] that
they've done all these years this thin
veil conservatism hiding their fascism
is the reason why we're in this [__]
situation in the first place
it's the whole reason why we're in this
situation keep going Liz I'm gonna show
you another clip too where you can tell
this [__] isn't genuine about it but go
ahead well he won't up he won't support
and uphold the Constitution we've
already seen what happened neither will
you the only history who attempted you
didn't stand in his way you piece of
[__] to stay in power after he had lost
um and the reason that we didn't have a
much more serious crisis okay she's
complaining about how he stayed in power
and he wouldn't leave it took
190 days 190 days from the election in
2020 for Liz Cheney as the leader in the
house Republican caucus to go to the
floor and say that he [__]
lost 190 days go count them go count
them the day that she went to the floor
and did that [__] I did a [__] Tik
Tock video and called her out on
it then and I'm doing it now too and I
ain't gonna stop no matter what so well
Liz Cheney now I'm I care about what she
does now that's the comments that I got
on a lot of the tweets is I care about
what Liz Cheney does now oh yeah okay
well and and Liz Cheney I'll fight side
by side with her are you you gonna fight
side by side with her when she takes
away women's rights to healthcare are
you g to fight side by side with her are
you g to fight side by side with Liz
jany as she tries to lower taxes for
billionaires in this country to rob the
[__] middle class worker are you
gonna do that are you gonna side with
Liz chany when she makes it to where
corporations not only don't have to pay
taxes but they get government welfare
from us the taxpayer all the while
[__] the American all the while [__]
the American worker you going to fight
with her side by side huh is that what
you're going to do because that's what
Liz Cheney is doing
dummies she's trying to [__] drum up
your support to support her and her thin
veil fascism [__] that [__] she can take
that book and stick it straight up her
ass stick it straight up her ass and
frankly frankly she could take all those
[__] books to the bombs of Liberty
[__] threesome parties and burn those
[__] when they have the book burning
after they have the
orgy I I mean I'm assuming that the moms
for Liberty the the the Min [__] have
threesoms and then they burn the books
or do they have the threesome after the
book burnings I don't know I I don't
know I don't know which one it is I have
no idea I have no idea guess what guess
what guess what dummies Liz Cheney Liz
Cheney loves the moms for Liberty
yeah she loves the moms for Liberty yeah
[__] yeah loves those
[__] okay keep going Liz keep
going I know this is hard but it's gonna
get it's it we're gonna get through this
this this was because there were people
around him who stopped him because there
were people around the country State
officials for example who stopped him
who did not yield to the pressure that
he oh oh so there's people around him
and stop kind of like um maybe maybe it
would have been cool if there would have
been I don't know a
congresswoman from Wyoming who was a
leader in the house Republican caucus I
wonder that would have been really cool
that have been really cool if she would
have stood in his way and stopped him
but she
didn't what the [__] what the [__] how
does how do people listen to this
[__] [__] and believe this trash huh
how do [__] people get such in a way
of cognitive dissonance that they just
blind themselves from the truth because
some [__] is saying what they
want to here this is the same stupid
[__] when I talk against Glenn in the
14th Amendment and people get pissed off
at me I'm just telling you the [__]
truth just because you don't want to
hear it and just because it doesn't feel
good to hear it doesn't mean it ain't
the [__]
truth she's telling you the [__]
truth she's projecting because she's a
[__] Republican that's what they do
best she ain't never gonna stop being a
[__]
Republican keep going on them to change
votes from Biden to Trump um we won't
have that Safeguard again and and he's
so dangerous if you have a president who
is unwilling to abide by the rulings of
the courts who's unwilling to uphold the
Constitution then there are no guard
rails who can stop him why in the [__]
then why in the [__] did it take you 190
days why you were the [__] guard rail
dummy you were the [__] guard rail
that's the whole point of the three
[__] branches it's the whole [__]
point and honestly this [__] stupid
[__] talks about and I don't know if
it's in this interview or another
interview she talks about if this
election gets thrown to
Congress and Mike Johnson is the Speaker
of the House you can't trust Republicans
and I think it's the next interview that
I'm going to show you that she says that
[__] you know what let's just go to that
one let's just go to that one let's just
go to that one because I'm gonna make my
point here because everyone thinks that
speaks now you guys don't but there's a
lot of people a lot of liberals think
I'm off my [__] rocker here when I'm
talking [__] about liis Cheney what the
fck what are you [__] [__]
me give me a [__]
break listen to this [__] the speaker of
the house is a collaborator to overthrow
the last election absolutely what
happens if Mike Johnson's the speaker on
the 6th of January 2025 he can't be you
know we're facing a situation with
respect to the 2024 election uh where
it's an existential crisis uh and we
have to ensure that we don't have a
situation where an election that might
be thrown into the House of
Representatives um is overseen by a
republican majority uh oh oh well what
about what about huh that's kind of
funny because because Liz Cheney was in
the [__] Congress in leadership on
January 6 2021 and that wasn't her view
it wasn't her view right directly after
or directly before H I wonder what could
have changed could it be that she's been
ousted from the Republican party and she
was ousted from leadership for telling
the truth the bare [__] [__]
minimum she did the bare minimum folks
she did the bare minimum she went to the
floor and she told the truth Trump lost
and she was
ousted she was ousted that's what the
[__] in the book about Kevin McCarthy
going down the mar Lago Kevin McCarthy
went down the mar Lago to beg Trump to
beg him to let him stay in the
Republican party after Kevin McCarthy
spoke out against him just the same day
as January 6 and Kevin McCarthy has
turned his [__] view in other words
he he knows the truth she knew the truth
and they wouldn't [__] tell
us they wouldn't [__] tell us and now
we're supposed to feel good and special
that they're telling us now [__] her
[__] [__] [__] her book [__] her lies
because she's a [__] liar she's a
liar when she's acting like she's just
now coming to this conclusion she's a
[__] liar she was okay with it she
was okay with
it when it when her power was safe when
her own power was
safe she was okay with
it it was only when her
power in Congress was questioned is when
she wasn't okay with it that's when she
turned keep going keep digging a hole
here so you would prefer a Dem
Democratic
majority watch watch her watch watch
watch her watch her just this is who she
is right here in this moment
[__] in this very moment watch
her watch what she says to this question
watch have a situation where an election
that might be thrown into the House of
Representatives um is overseen by a
republican majority so you would prefer
Democratic
majority that's all you [__] need to
know that's all you need to
know that's
it because the fact of the matter is is
Liz Cheney is a [__] fascist Liz
Cheney wants to take away women's rights
Liz Cheney wants to take away your
[__] rights she wants to have a
national Religion she wants everything
daddy Darth fader
wanted all of it she loves Trump ISM she
doesn't like
Trump she loves
trumpism and in this moment right
here so you would prefer a democratic
majority
there's the moment right there that's
all you need that's all I've needed and
I've been telling you for years years
it's it's it's it's gonna be three
[__] years it's gonna be three
[__] years that I've been telling you
this
[__] about this that about this [__]
just Nazi I've been telling
you she did the bare minimum she told
the truth eventually and now she's
trying to get you
liberals to buy her book because now
she's on your
side [__] that [__] you ain't on my side
uh-uh nope I don't dine with Nazis
I don't dine with Nazis ain't a thing
ain't a thing watch the rest of it it it
almost gets better I believe very
strongly in those principles and ideals
that have defined the Republican party
oh oh there it is there it is oh there
it is there it is [__]
democracy all those defining principles
of republicanism that has let us down
the Road where fascism is trying to take
hold in this country and destroy our
democracy she believes in all that she
believes in M make America great again
all those great values the Tea
Party questioning Obama's birth
certificate and where he was
born all that good Republican value [__]
you know what I mean making sure women
are forced to give birth
even if their even if their [__]
lives are at risk Force 12 year olds to
give birth believing that women [__]
abort babies after they're
born limiting what books parents can let
their children
read burning them if you have
to and I'm the [__] one that's crazy
but the Republican party of today has
made a choice and they haven't chosen
the Constitution and so I do think it's
a it presents a threat if the
Republicans are in the majority in
January 2025 but she won't say that the
Democrat should be in the majority so
which is it Liz huh which is it do you
care about your future power in your
Republican party which is dead dead
dead or do you believe in
democracy folks this is the same this is
the same stupid [__] that we're having
to ask the people on the left who are
[__]
pramas it's the same dumb [__] same
thing same [__] thing same [__] they
are the people who are
pramas on the
left and who have this diluted view that
somehow Hamas is freeing pales Palestine
and somehow that's the way to
Palestinians Liberty it's the same
[__] cognitive dissidence
it's a special stupid kind of cognitive
dissonance but that's what it is because
you ain't getting with the [__]
truth [__] Liz Cheney won't and and
and and a lot of people came at me on
Twitter they were like well the
interviewer didn't ask these questions
that's because the interviewer wasn't
allowed to ask these questions I don't
know if you know how book tours work and
how [__] profit in news works but the
[__] you pay me model is get a book get
a big name get a get a [__] interview
do a prime time oh Rachel matad is gonna
do a big Prime Time interview
tonight and I hope to God Rachel mat ask
these questions and I know there's MSNBC
producers that watch this [__] show
so listen up and you better walk this
[__] question on down to Rachel's
[__] part of the office if you're
[__]
listening here's the
question why now why not in 2016 were
you listening to Hillary Clinton do you
owe Hillary Clinton an apology for not
listening to what she was saying do you
owe people an apology for supporting
Donald Trump through his first
impeachment supporting him through
January 6 and Beyond January 6 by not
using your power as a leader in the
house caucus to speak out against
him
huh
huh do you owe America an apology for
what you
did and now you're telling Americans to
not do what you did and you not
admitting you did it let me tell you
something if Liz Cheney doesn't get
right with the truth and tell the
American people that she knew Donald
Trump was a threat the entire time and
she used her power to elevate him and
she apologizes for it all this nonsense
about her loving democracy will fall on
deaf
ears and that's the point that I want to
make it doesn't matter what the [__] Liz
Cheney says folks because Liz CH is just
saying the [__] we all
know Liz CH is just saying the [__] we
all
know until Liz Cheney comes out publicly
and says I [__] apologize I'm
responsible for elevating Trump and the
Republican party to what it is
today I want to change what the
Republican party is I want them to
support democracy and
Liberty and I I led them down the road
as a leader of the House us against
democracy and in support of
fascism I want to make sure that women
had the right to [__] health care
that they have the right to privacy in
their doctor's office I'm going to
change my views on these issues because
I realize that these white Christian
nationalist views are what caused this
problem in the first place this is not a
trump problem folks Trump is not the
disease he's the symptom of the disease
he's the symptom and the disease the
disease is [__] super [__] deep in
this
one this person has a [__]
disease and she knows
it and she's trying to profit off the
fact that you think she doesn't have the
disease
anymore and again I love hearing Liz
Cheney say this [__]
same way with Chris Christie if Chris
Christie doesn't [__] apologize for
what he did to the American
people by [__] elevating and propping
up Trump when they knew who the [__] he
was and they knew the danger that he
posed to our American democracy until
they do that all the [__] they all the
[__] they speak out against Trump will
fall on DEA
ears and it's all for nothing
it's all for profit [__] you pay me for
my
book every single [__] bit of it
because this [__] that she's talking in
these interviews people were saying this
very same [__] in
2016 and 2020 when Liz Cheney was
supporting Donald Trump and his type of
fascism and I appreciate that Liz Cheney
wants and anyone who wants to sound the
alarm but glossing
over that you had to ignore all the
signs before
this is just a different type of
cognitive
dissidence and you ain't selling me I
ain't buying that kind of
[__] I don't buy that MAA [__] I
don't buy that [__] and I don't buy that
somehow l he didn't know the threat of
trump the only thing I know is she knows
the game of [__] you pay me [__] you pay
me just like Bill bar knows it John
Bolton knows it John Kelly knows it
[__] Jonathan Carl knows it Bob
Woodward knows
it all of them book after book after
book profiting off our [__] demise of
our democracy so they can get some money
in their [__]
pocket [__] them [__] them speaking of
putting money in the pocket I don't know
if you heard this this is breaking news
um I'm I'm serious this is breaking news
Donald Trump broke this at his rally in
Iowa listen to this you see they just
found him5 billion went to him remember
during the debate I said to Joe Biden I
said how come the mayor of you see they
just found him5 billion went to him $5
billion went to him breaking news Joe
Biden's net worth is more than Donald
Trump's this guy's such a [__]
idiot you know why again it was five
million then it was 20 now it's 40 a lot
of Republicans like James qan on comr
and Jim Jordan are claiming it's $40
million went to the Biden family a lot
of these [__] chuckleheads are
claiming that [__] and ain't anywhere
close the only [__] money they found
from Biden to Biden is James Biden paid
back a loan to Joe Biden that had no
interest for 200 Grand not even close to
[__] $5 million let alone five
billion the only reason why this dumb
[__] said five billion is because he
gets billions and millions confused in
his own head because of his stupid
yapping yapping his trap about Mar Lago
that's it that's all it
is but that I mean if if Donald Trump is
claiming that Joe Biden reed5
billion then the breaking news there is
that Joe Biden's net worth is much more
than Donald Trump's and it's it'll
definitely be a lot more after the
[__] New York civil case is
done um I also have breaking news here
here is um Bridget Bridget Ziggler the
moms for Liberty um apparently they have
a a new um a new merch drop
here is this real or is it AI I mean
even if the shirt's not real even if
this image isn't
real isn't this how she feels right I
don't know I mean here's the thing we
were talking about this you know over
the weekend I was talking about this
with some people and I was like in this
kind of
crazy and a couple people brought up
some good points right and I I don't
know if you sexual deviants have ever
done some crazy [__] in a bedroom and
you know invited someone in or you
invited in someone's
bedroom but I
mean in a
threesome you know it doesn't have to be
gay right like you know if there's two
dudes and one gal the two dudes don't
have to you know do the thing I and if
there's two gals and one guy the two
girls don't have to do the thing right I
mean they don't have
to but if you watch enough porn they do
you know I'm I'm just saying I'm just
saying and again everyone's got their
own little Kink I'm not Kink shaming
honestly I'm not Kink shame shaming um
Bridget Ziggler if this is real you know
maybe she does like to eat [__] I don't
know I don't know it's really [__]
possible though isn't
it isn't it it's really [__]
Possible Oh my God L listen the best
part about this is that um moms for
Liberty have totally ruined their
credibility uh and they won't be able to
walk away from this like any kind of
public events that they do any kind any
kind of [__] things they they post
now now is going to be tied to them
having orgies and
threes right I mean it's that's just
what's going to happen they're not going
to be able to get away from this and
that's the that's the best part about it
it's the best part um I I got the clip
of U and I got so much more I want to
show you that happened over the weekend
there was Pro Palestinian um uh
protesters which I'm not I'm not against
the peaceful protest by any means but
there was protesters that went to a
Jewish restaurant in Philadelphia they
targeted a Jewish restaurant because a
Jewish person owned the restaurant which
is [__] well
beyond just a peaceful protest I don't
know if you know that or not but that's
what it is um but there's this clip too
uh in Iowa there's so many other clips
from Iowa that I'd like to show you but
he's [__] irrelevant but this one's
relevant in the realm of saying the
quiet part out loud listen to this but
we've been waging an allout war in
American democracy what was that Grandpa
say that again but we've been waging an
allout war in American democracy you
what what wait what you been what what
have you been doing but we've been
waging an allout war in American
democracy you holy [__] I guess make
America great again means waging an all
out war on American democracy hey
hey internet SLO don't just cut that
clip and put it on a loop there's no way
I'll post it on my YouTube channel no
way no way would I post that on my
YouTube channel
oink ah everyone knows who I'm talking
about I want to thank um all the people
in the background who helped this show
all the [__] fam all of you guys all
you guys we're getting to the holidays
and we're going to have um some days off
near Christmas Christmas and New Year's
but I want to thank all of you rather
you listen to the show if you go over to
the patreon and you follow for free or
you support me um financially it it
means a lot to me I know it means a lot
to my family because this is how I make
a living now and you guys keep this
microphone powered on and to all the
people out there that are behind the
scenes the mods we got the best group of
the best Mod Squad ever here at the Tony
Michaels podcast always give them love
they give you love when you come in the
chat give them love when you're here
show them some holiday love uh mighty
librarian over at library democracy
she's going to be putting out a ton of
content on Project 2025 that we are
going to absolutely make sure that we
give attention to so follow follow the
library of democracy just go to Library
of democracy on YouTube Follow the
library of democracy there U skip G
getting the clip Master skip clipping me
up making me look pretty on shorts on
YouTube YouTube Derek going out on the
internet and all the people who help
Derek find those videos uh murf and so
many other people who help Derek find
those videos and post those on the
YouTube channel I don't know if you guys
have noticed but we're going to get more
and more and more posted over there
because there's a lot of clips that I
can't show you on the show and we want
to show you those clips you got to see
those
clips uh the other thing the other thing
that the other people Ty Ross I want to
thank Ty she does so much stuff in the
background that no one sees but I want
to give Ty some
love and U um to the guy with the last
name Sanchez I wouldn't be here without
him I know he has his own show now and I
know some people are disappointed that
he's not on this show but Gabe is doing
great things over on his channel and
what was that live and I'm so happy and
I'm glad that I get to spend time with
him on bonehead of the week and some
other times during the week but he's
doing great work so I want to I want to
thank that guy as well and there's so
many others out there all the people who
show up for the producers corner all the
people who support me on patreon all of
you that send whether you're sending
vimo super chats in you're you're buying
me Shots you're putting money in the
Square jar or you guys go buy the new
tattoo merch so many people have loved
the my dog and even my cat hates Tech
Cruise merch you guys support me in that
way and keep this microphone powered and
I can't thank everyone
enough because you guys you guys mean
the world to me all the people on the
Facebook group all the people who
participate in the bone of the week poll
all the people who engage on this show
come here every single [__] day and
chat even the people who because I'm
banned on Facebook left Facebook and
come over here even though they don't
exactly like this chat they prefer the
Facebook
Chat all every single last one of
you every single last one of
you means so much
to this show and you are what keeps this
microphone powered for fascism don't
forget that because that's our main
fight every single day because the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty same time same
place tomorrow go to Theon mich.com and
find your way into support me as I cough
my way out and of course I got wait I
got to I got to thank the rat rat rat we
got to think the rat I forgot the rat
who could forget the rat the rats in the
background chick Shing baby chit Ching
me and rat will be back tomorrow same
time same place you know where to find
us surf up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at@ the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
Beacon
they want to talk about your dishwashers
and how much water you're going to have
in your dishwasher even though they
don't work and all of the other things
that you have that were so precious and
dear and that you never really
appreciated until now because they want
to take them away You're Heating and
Cooling in your house they want to
change it they want to change everything
these people sick these people are sick
not in his house right not in his they
want to talk about
you